stolen here comes lebron here's that
transition that michael malone was
talking to us
about today they make the stop they go
the other way and they get the deuce and
lebron takes it in
he's got seven and a steal now here by
the lakers
number one defensive team in the nba
shrewd around side caldwell
pope three he is a top ten three-point
shooter that's half with the rebound
bart schroeder screened by milsap switch
on d
over davis into murray
yokoch on top down low millsap
shot clock at five martin outside wide
open triple teeing it up murray for
three for the nuggets
dribble penetration cap we saw this last
year
in orlando from this nuggets team
martin right there nice job there
sucking the defense in
denver is rushed it they were supposed
to play detroit earlier this week but
there were
some health and protocol issues with the
pistons the game was cancelled
and the nuggets really could have used
it and they took advantage here's a nice
try
by lebron two in a row right down the
boulevard he's got nine
jeff doesn't always seem like lebron
james is playing downhill
it does all the time nice spinner right
there put up it in by murray
and he puts in five and three shots to
begin things
you see the field goal story right there
the history making night tonight passing
the former laker will chamberlain former
jayhawk driving his
caldwell pope
[Applause]
[Music]
and just because i want to get the water
cooler a little bit buzzing
tomorrow you know this is the one
question i get from all my cycling
buddies like justin and corey williams
payson mcelveen
who is the greatest of all time and i
try to tell them
you know we talk about tom brady who's
getting ready to play in his 10th super
bowl
you know the the excellence that we've
seen over a long
time between these two players i tell
people this
if we were playing shirts and skins and
i was playing
i would probably want to be on the
bronze team because
mj and i played the same position if i'm
up in the stands and i'm watching them
to play
who am i going for there's no question
number 23
jordan